been making minecraft costumes for like
a week now okay so the big ol spaceman
hanging out there's nowhere Saturn
oh there it is Thursday Saturn yeah good
idea string the lights on jacob bringing
you a present no we had your ism
Holograms
there's a giant shirt there is a sharp
an elephant of fire satellite national
two hours later
that's not Saturn Earth that's not what
has anyone seen my shoe
stupid dinosaurs sniffing my shoe
thinking it opossum me you know these
suspenders I am just creating the
suspension system for these pants
zombies start their day with a nice
flesh bath you got to be nice and clean
if you're going to be eating the souls
of the living so after that they usually
go wander around aimlessly and then when
the Sun comes out they burn and die I'll
go to Holograms how do I select so you
reach out your pressure and you don't
just there's a little dot mesentery of
you so line that data all you want to
click on and how are you going to put
out your pointer you really like this
OOP okay there's only one hand oh yes
you got a rather fantastic t-rex dude
that's frightening and there is a very
pleasant unicorn I put a video player
there and my computer monitor there it's
thing over here something exists and
like access different things so can you
guys guess what I'm making now Deborah a
zebra exactly Carmichael we're not
allowed to call them zebras no we do not
have them hit that coffee too hard man
it's 5:00 p.m. I need it
this is the worst spray-paint ever this
is like the cheapest Dolph left and I
know it's enamel that's probably why
it's being so shitty right now but when
I spray it on literally just glosses off
so I go to store and buy more Matt let
them do a second coat dry
I let the first coat dry overnight I'll
peel off the tape and the ref body and
the arms and the legs we'll be done
oh man when you scan it's so crazy I'm
scanning right now it's hope it's like
mapping out all the geometry in the area
that is so high-tech here I'm gonna scan
you ready so right now I am getting
started on the John Cena minecraft Cena
instead of the normal this box minecraft
torso it's going to be slightly contour
like he's ripped you know it's going to
be slightly more difficult to make this
one because I have to cut out each panel
separately and then fix them together
somehow this short is super heavy on
stunts my worry is that the costumes
aren't gonna last past the first or
second take I have to wonder how many
people have ridden a hoverboard wearing
one of these things I wonder how many
people I've written a 1 wheel
don't you dare crash and braven hololens
you can't see my flashback
okay cool how's this oh yeah there we go
or that way you can see a lot of help
like the person is getting to bounce
this in like that don't go blind in the
hoverboard scan traffic going forwards
backwards a certain point so I'm pretty
sure to play it something from the
future
hold on stare there
I should put like things as long between
Holograms I'm going to do the world's
farol over dick you hollow lens transfer
from a one wheel my hand is to me that
tighten anybody want to solar system
it's kind of crazy to astronauts bigger
than it's all your fault Peter it's all
your fault all your phone